[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem ersten tag des jahres sowie zahn
ist auch wieder dabei für den sport
hallo schönen guten abend und das sind
die wichtigsten themen von heute
willkommen im neuen jahr deutschland
begrüßt
2022 mit weniger feuerwerk verletzte gab
es denn
umstrittene änderung beim umweltschutz
die eu will bestimmte gas und
atomkraftwerke als klimafreundlich
einstufen und
neujahrsspringen in garmisch während
markus eisenbichler über platz zwei
jubelt kann karl geiger seine tournee
hoffnung praktisch begraben
dieser jahreswechsel begann im fernsehen
durchaus ungewöhnlich mit dem
gesundheitsminister der licht am ende
des tunnels verspricht dazu gab es
draußen trotz verkaufsverbot
überraschend viel ballerei und leider
auch einige unfälle und ausschreitungen
christoph distel über licht und schatten
in der silvesternacht
diesmal keine sause am brandenburger tor
erklärt die polizei am silvesterabend
vielen ratlosen in der hauptstadt die
alle feiern wollen und plötzlich nicht
mehr wissen hoch im fernsehen zumindest
auf die party steigen wie gewohnt am tor
mit countdown und digitalem feuerwerk
ins neue jahr mit promis und vielen
zuschauern aber eben nur in deren
wohnzimmern
schon am abend hatten sie stichwort
corona vom gesundheitsminister die
vorsichtig frohe kunde in sachen omikron
vernommen
doppelter grund also zum feiern und
abgesehen von kleineren ausschreitungen
etwa in stuttgart und leipzig dies meist
glatt und ruhig gab ja auch kein
feuerwerk zu kaufen aber doch man sieht
hier in hamburg wohl noch ziemlich viel
privat auf lager wie sich auch bei den
wenigen tragödien der nach zeigte berlin
friedrichshagen private feier ist knallt
plötzlich schreie eine explosion aus der
kontrolle zwölf verletzte darunter auch
kinder anwohner sind zugleich geschockt
und verständnislos den findet sind mich
schon sehr viel zu viel rettungskräfte
die wollen das auf jeden fall
mehr gebraucht werden und
definitiv nichts einlassen schlimmer
noch hennef bei bonn private feier zwei
männer zünden einen selbstgebauten
kracher auf einer wiese riesenknall
einer der beiden 37 jahre alt stirbt der
andere 39 jahre kommt schwer verletzt in
eine klinik
gesund und haben froh ins neue jahr im
vom hochwasser gebeutelten aartal bekam
anwohner das hinein jahr corona hatten
sie schon in den knochen als die große
flut ihnen fast den rest gab da wird man
zurückhaltend mit den wünschen fürs neue
jahr mal gucken ob 22 das hält was 21
versprochen hat aber tanzen geht ja
immer fröhlich und zuversichtlich sein
auch im aartal und anderswo
auch im neuen jahr gilt impfen als das
instrument gegen die pandemie deshalb
gab es im hamburger rathaus heute eine
impfaktion stadt neujahrsempfang
spritzen statt sekt über 1000 dosen
wurden hier verimpft die zahl der korona
neuinfektionen liegt aktuell bei 26
184 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages hinzu die sieben tage inzidenz
steigt auf
220,3 allerdings sind die zahlen laut rp
wegen der feiertage unvollständig
nachhaltig und umweltfreundlich was
diesen stempel trägt verkauft sich
besser wir kennen das von lebensmitteln
die eu will dieses gütesiegel jetzt auch
an gas und atomkraftwerke verleihen das
lockt private investoren umweltverbände
und politiker aber bringt es auf die
barrikaden vor allem in deutschland das
in diesem jahr komplett aus der
atomkraft aussteigt gunnar krüger
brüssel am neujahrstag die einen haben
gefeiert die anderen haben gearbeitet
und punkt 0 uhr definiert was ein grünes
investment sei zwei punkte sind
umstritten punkt eins ist die atomkraft
die einstufung als grüne technologie
würde privates geld von
klimafreundlichen anlegern in den erhalt
alter und den bau neuer kraftwerke
lenken damit kommt die eu-kommission
frankreich entgegen das voll auf
atomkraft setzt aber nicht deutschland
in deutschland hat einen sonderweg
beschritten aber wir können nicht von
allen 27 staaten verlangen unserem
sonderweg zu folgen wir sollten anderen
staaten auch ermöglichen ihren weg zu
gehen das ziel heißt klimaneutralität
und dem hat sich alles unterzuordnen den
weg zum ziel soll punkt 2 auch erdgas
ebenen doch selbst moderne kraftwerke
schaden dem klima neubauten sollen darum
nur als grün gelten wenn sie noch
schmutzige kohlekraftwerke ersetzen wenn
sie nur dann einspringen wenn wind und
sonne fehlen und wenn sie zügig
umgestellt werden etwa auf wasserstoff
doch die abstriche reichen nicht allen
wir befürchten das ist jetzt eben wieder
attraktiver wird in atom- oder aber auch
in fossile energie zu investieren das
ist genau das falsche signal denn wir
brauchen einen massiven ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien und dafür brauchen
wir auch privates kapital doch die
großen in der eu stützen den vorschlag
der kommission mal offen mal
stillschweigend atomkraft für frankreich
erdgas für deutschland dieser
europäische kompromiss könnte dem ausbau
der erneuerbaren das geld entziehen so
die befürchtung an der basis von rot und
grün
auch zwei grüne regierungsmitglieder in
deutschland haben schon protestiert
wirtschaftsminister herr beck und
umweltministerin
lemke gunnar krüger in brüssel aber
bislang handelt es sich erst mal nur um
einen vorschlag oder
ja es handelt sich um einen vorschlag
aber natürlich um einen mit ziemlich
guten chancen auf umsetzung denn in
diesem fall müssten sich 20 von 27
mitgliedstaaten schon dagegen stellen
und das ist doch eher unwahrscheinlich
denn die kommission holt er gerade die
mitgliedstaaten dort ab wo sie herkommen
also frankreich zum beispiel beim
atomstrom oder die osteuropäer beim
erdgas und deutschland deutschland kann
sich ja fast so eine neutrale position
leisten natürlich auch um streit zu
vermeiden streit zwischen rot und grün
streit zwischen der basis und der
führung dieser parteien kanzler scholz
hat ja mal gesagt das sei doch nur eine
ganz ein ganz kleines thema bei einer
ganz großen frage aber das natürlich
kräftig untertrieben denn diese grüne
taxonomie wie das im fachjargon heißt
die hat natürlich enorme lenkungswirkung
die könnte tatsächlich mehr milliarden
in den klimaschutz lenken als es zum
beispiel der aufbau von der
eu-kommission machen könnte also das
ganze könnte mehr für den klimaschutz
bringen wenn unter diesem grünen label
wirklich steckt was es verspricht
danke für diese einschätzung live aus
brüssel grüne krüger
durchschnittlich 44 euro pro monat so
viel bekommen ab heute pflegebedürftige
im heim und ihre angehörigen als
zuschuss zu ihrem eigenanteil
44 euro von der pflegeversicherung als
erste entlastung das wird zwar mit den
jahren deutlich mehr trotzdem bringt die
reform den
820.000 heimbewohnern und ihren
angehörigen wenig sagen
patientenschützer anna basbug
elisabeth neuwirth ist demenzkrank seit
vier jahren lebt die 97-jährige hier im
pflegeheim in albershausen nahe
stuttgart für die rundumbetreuung seit
ihre tochter jeden monat
3442 euro eigenanteil um das irgendwie
zu finanzieren musste die 70 jährige
rentnerin das haus der familie verkaufen
das ganze geld von dem haus aufgebraucht
und
da ich als tochter die einzige bin die
eventuell noch herangezogen werden kann
und ich ganz geringe rente habe werde
ich wahrscheinlich auf sozialamt gehen
müssen menschen wie marianne herre und
ihre 97 jährige mutter sollen ab januar
2022 finanziell entlastet werden unter
anderem sieht die reform vor dass die
pflegekasse künftig im ersten jahr
heimaufenthalt 5 prozent des
eigenanteils trägt im 225
im dritten jahr 45 prozent danach 70
außerdem gibt es künftig eine milliarde
euro zuschuss jährlich vom bund zur
pflegeversicherung
trotzdem bleibt die belastung für die
pflegebedürftigen und deren familien
hoch auch durch steigende energie- und
personalkosten der heime etwa
ein wirksames mittel dagegen wäre
unserer meinung nach eben zum beispiel
gewesen wenn im koalitionsvertrag die
zusammenlegung der gesetzlichen und
privaten pflegeversicherung beschlossen
worden wäre leistungen sind komplett
identisch in der privaten ist noch so
viel rücklage wenig lob für die neue
pflegereform also bevor sie überhaupt in
kraft getreten ist es bleibt bei vielen
die sorge wer kann sich pflege künftig
überhaupt noch leisten
weitere änderungen ab heute vom
plastiktüten verbot bis zum höheren
mindestlohn kompakt zusammengefasst
können sie das auf unserer zdf heute app
nachlesen
warum werden menschen berufsunfähig die
häufigste ursache sind psychische
störungen seit jahren steigt die zahl
rund 41 prozent waren ist 2020 meldet
der lebensversicherer dbk er hat die
daten von rund
480.000 versicherten ausgewertet mit
großem abstand folgen krebserkrankungen
und dann an dritter stelle beschwerden
an rücken- oder gelenken
er hat die welt zu einem besseren ort
gemacht so hieß es heute zum abschied
von desmond tutu volksheld südafrikas
friedens-nobelpreisträger und
engagierter kämpfer gegen apartheid und
umweltschutz berühmt auch für seinen
humor und seine bescheidenheit vor knapp
einer woche war der erzbischof mit 90
gestorben zuvor hatte er genaue
anweisungen für seine trauerfeier
gegeben sind heißt
in einem schlichten kiefern sagt wird
der leichnam von desmond tutu in dießen
george kathedrale in kapstadt gebracht
er hatte sich ausdrücklich das
günstigste modell gewünscht
klein von statur war er ein riese unter
uns moralisch und spirituell
sein freund nelson mandela drückte es
perfekt aus als er sagte manchmal
schrill oft weich nie besorgt und selten
ohne humor
das motto stimme wird immer die stimme
derer sein die keine haben
1975 wird tutu erster schwarzer dekan in
johannesburg elf jahre später
anglikanische erzbischof und kapstadt
tutu nutzte seine ämter er kämpfte gegen
die ungerechtigkeit der apartheid
1984 bekommt er den friedensnobelpreis
ernst bischof desmond tutu war ohne
frage ein kreuzritter im kampf um
freiheit gerechtigkeit
gleichheit und frieden
im kreis der familie wird tutus asche
hier in der kathedrale beigesetzt werden
von deren kanzel er so oft gegen die
brutalität des apartheid-regimes
predigte
jetzt bist du dran mit dem wintersport
skispringer markus eisenbichler knüpft
bei der vierschanzentournee an seine
gute form an und belegt beim
neujahrsspringen in
garmisch-partenkirchen den zweiten platz
sieger wie schon in oberstdorf der
japaner ryo kobayashi
nur der wimpernschlag von 0,2 punkten
fehlt zum sieg herausragende sprünge mit
weiten von 141 143 eineinhalb metern
bringen markus eisenbichler beim
neujahrsspringen auf platz zwei und in
der gesamtwertung der tournee auf rang
vier nächte kurz gefühl auf der schanze
zufrieden
den sieg sichert sich wie schon beim
auftaktspringen in oberstdorf der
japaner hiroyuki kobayashi der seine
führung in der gesamtwertung ausbaute
tagesdritter wird überraschend der
slowene logos frustrierend dagegen der
tag von karl geiger in
garmisch-partenkirchen bei rückenwind
fällt er als tages siebter auf platz
sechs der gesamtwertung zurück und
review kobayashi benötigt einen neuen
pokal scherben bringen ja glück
weiter im eis rennrodler johannes ludwig
feiert seinen vierten saisonsieg der
olympia-dritte gewinnt das weltcup
rennen in winterberg und führt den
gesamtweltcup weiter souverän an für den
oberhofer der siebte podestplatz im
olympischen winter
buchstäblich ein feiertag in zweifacher
hinsicht für die deutschen rodler bei
schwierigen bedingungen durch hohe
temperaturen in winterberg profitiert
der doppelsitzer mit tobias wendl und
tobias arlt von stürzen der konkurrenz
im letzten durchgang rund vier
hundertstel vorsprung im ziel
gleichbedeutend mit dem ersten
saisonsieg für das du bereits ist zum
vierten mal ganz oben auf dem podium in
diesem weltcup winter nur eines ludwig
im einsitzer der 35-jährige triumphiert
nach einem überzeugenden zweiten
durchgang und führt damit weiterhin
souverän die weltcup gesamtwertung an
nationaltorhüter manuel neuer und drei
weitere spieler des fc bayern münchen
haben sich mit dem corona virus
infiziert das gab der rekordmeister am
abend bekannt neben neuer wurden auch
kingsley koman kontert olli so oma
richards sowie co-trainer dino
toppmöller positiv getestet sie befinden
sich alle in häuslicher isolation
ja das war es vom sport engagement bitte
nicht vorenthalten wollen wir ihnen den
blick in die ferne silvesterparty welt
einer der größten findet in der regel am
times square in new york statt mit
traditionellen countdown diesmal
allerdings wegen corona mit deutlich
weniger und nur mit geimpften gesten
oder rio de janeiro in brasilien
vielleicht wird das neue jahr ja so
schön wie das feuerwerk an der
copacabana
der himmel hierzulande funkelt deutlich
weniger im süden gibt es morgen sonne im
norden dagegen wird es trüb und sehr
regnerisch abends sind im westen
gewitter möglich dabei weht ein
kräftiger wind bei 8 bis 16 grad
das war die erste 19 uhr sendung
2022 danke fürs dabeisein ich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen neujahrsabend
die nächsten nachrichten können sie um
23 uhr 18 sehen und uns morgen wieder um
7 auf wiedersehen
[Musik]